If you were to define what it meant to be
a banana, you had to tick every box on that
list and then you could be nothing but a banana.
We're going to look at a sequence and show that
it converges to a limit you weren't expecting. So
the sequence is as follows: the first term is 9,
second term is 99, third term 999.
Fourth term - you guessed it - four 9s;
and we're going to continue with this pattern.
So obviously this sequence goes to infinity.
We're adding more and more 9s, so in the
usual sense this is a divergent sequence;
it goes to infinity, it's getting bigger.
But I'm going to show you that in fact
this tends to -1. This sequence of adding more
and more 9s, making the number larger and larger,
in a certain situation can be shown to tend to -1.
And here's how it works. First of all we need to
establish what we mean by saying a sequence tends
to a particular number. This might seem like
something you know, or you've seen before, but
this is going to be really important in justifying
why this is -1 so bear with me. So if we start
with a different sequence; so suppose I have 3/2,
4/3, 5/4, 6/5 and it's going to continue. So
we're adding 1 to each of the numerators - numbers
on top - and we're adding 1 to each number on
the bottom. So the nth term, if we would sort
of go along and say pick a certain point in the
sequence, what does the nth term look like at that
position? It's going to be n plus 2 over n plus
1. So first term, plug it in, we get 3 on the top
over 2. Third term here this would be n equals 3,
we get 5 on top 4 on the bottom. Whatever position
down you might say to me, find the 1000th
term in the sequence, it's a 1002 over 1001.
Now this hopefully you can see is going to tend
to 1. As we increase n, we go further and further
along the sequence, the top and the bottom
get closer and closer together. So we can
get as close to 1 as we want by going
further and further down the sequence.
So the way we would show that is you take
your nth term - which here is n plus 2 over
n plus 1 - and we subtract off what we think the
limit is, so here we think it's going to be 1,
and then we work out the distance between these
two. So I'm calling this our distance function.
Now if we're working in the real numbers - which
these are all real numbers - then the distance
function is just the modulus of one number
subtract the other. So we take the modulus
because it's a distance so it should be positive
- you can't really have a negative distance. So
here the distance in the real numbers is n
plus 2 over n plus 1 minus 1. What is n plus
2 over n plus 1? Well we can simplify that
and say, well that's actually the same as n
plus 1 plus another 1 all over n plus 1 minus 1.
But then we've got an n plus 1 over an n plus 1
so that's a 1 so we can say that's actually 1 plus
1 over n plus 1 minus 1 so we get 1 over n plus 1.
So again, with this distance function the usual
way of measuring distance, we can show that the
nth term of the sequence and what we think the
limit is; we can say the distance between them
looks like 1 over n plus 1. So as we now go
further and further down the sequence what
we're doing is we're letting n tend to infinity.
We're making n bigger and bigger, what happens
to our distance as n gets bigger, the distance
tends to zero. So as n tends to infinity, the
distance between the two things is 1 over n plus 1
which very clearly tends to zero, so we would say
this sequence converges to 1. And we've done that
using the distance function, which for the real
numbers is just modulus of one of them minus the
other. I'm going to need more paper. Asalways.
The reason I've introduced the distance
function, as some of you may have guessed, is
if we're going to show our sequence of 9s
is tending to -1 we obviously can't use the
normal definition of distance because the distance
between a larger larger number and -1 is getting
bigger so it's it's just not going to work, it's
not going to tend to zero. So we need to think
about what other definition of distance can we use
to show that this sequence is indeed going to -1.
And the one we use is called the 2-adic metric -
and we will check this is a distance. You say the
distance between two numbers x and y. So x and
y are going to be integers because here in our
sequence we're only working with integers so we'll
keep things simple. So the distance between two
integers in this metric is defined to be 1 divided
by 2 to the m, where m is the largest power of 2
that divides x minus y. So this feels a little
complicated, so let's look at an example, let's
think about what does this mean. Let's suppose
x is 100 and y is 4. So in the usual measure of
distance we would say the modulus of x minus y
is the modulus of 100 minus 4, they're 96 apart.
Feels hopefully kind of obvious. Now in the 2-adic
metric we've changed our definition of distance,
so we need to think about what power of 2 divides
their difference. So we already know the difference,
the difference between them is 96. So if we think
of powers of 2 we've got 2, 4, 8, 16, 32, 64. 128 is
obviously too big so I'm going to stop there. 64,
well that's 2 to the 6, but 64 doesn't divide 96.
It's smaller than it but 64 times 2 - which would
be the next smallest thing you could have - wouldn't
give you 96. So we actually need to go down to
2 to the 5, which is 32, which perfectly divides
96. So 2 to the 5 is 32, 32 times 3 gives us 96.
2 to the 5 divides the difference between our
numbers so, in our definition, we can say in the
2-adic metric the distance between 100 and 4 is 1
over 2 to the biggest power, so here 2 to the
5, so that's going to be 1 over 32. So usual
definition of distance that we're all used to,
these numbers are 96 apart, 100 and 4. However in this
metric they are 1 over 32 apart; which doesn't
feel at all natural and-
- (Brady: Or useful)
- Or useful. I
mean well that's a whole other conversation.
We're entering the realm of pure maths. This-
now that you've set me off on this - it is useful
because we learn properties about the numbers.
So this kind of Investigation, okay this isn't
a distance in our world, but we can learn things
about distributions of numbers through this. Ao
this 2-adic metric can be generalised and is
used to actually in fields medal level research
to learn about rational numbers. So beyond beyond
my pay grade, beyond my ability to do the
maths, but there is some usefulness in there.
So we've got our 2-adic metric. So I've just
told you this is a way of figuring out how
far apart two numbers are, but you need to check
from a mathematical perspective that it does
everything you would expect a distance measure
to do. So we have a set of axioms. In order to be
a distance function: it maps from two numbers in
our starting space into the real numbers, we get
an answer that's a real number. Where d satisfies
three things - this one's called positivity. And
these should hopefully fit with your intuition
of what we might expect from a distance. If
we have two numbers x and y, the distance
between them is greater than or equal to zero.
We're talking about distances, okay they might
not fit our usual way we think about them, but
they still need to be positive. You can't have
a non-positive distance, negative distance
makes no sense. And in fact you can say and it
equals zero if and only if x is equal to y. So
you only have a zero distance if it's the same
point. Again, hopefully fits with our usual notion.
Second one is called symmetry, so this says the
distance between x and y- so if I start with x
and move to a point y, I should obviously get
the same thing if I start at y and move back
to x. d of x,y is d of y,x - quite straightforward.
Doesn't matter where we start. The third one is
called the triangle law. Now this one is best seen
by picture; if I start at point x and I want to
go to point z then what this says is moving
directly from x to z is always going to be
faster than going via some third point y.
Again, fits our usual way of thinking about
distances. If you're thinking about the usual
measure of distance this is saying the shortest
way to move between two points in the plane is a
straight line. Of course it changes if you're on
spheres and changing your geometry. In terms of our
function that says the distance between x and z
has to be less than or equal to - so it's shorter
than - going by a detour. So if we did d(x,y) plus d(y,z)
written out algebraically. So these three axioms,
three rules, need to be satisfied in order for
a function d to be called a distance in terms
of the mathematical definition of a distance. So
we just need to check that our 2-adic metric
satisfies these three things; because at this
point you're just taking my word that this is
a reasonable thing to do, even though we get a
rather ridiculous answer. So we do want to verify
this. Let's write down our definition, 1 over 2
to the m where the m was the largest power of 2
that divides their difference. So is this positive?
It's one over a power of 2, that's certainly a
positive number. So we can say that works. We're
all good. Symmetry: if I do the distance between x
and y, is that the same as doing y and x? Well here
we were finding the largest power of 2 that
divided x minus y. So what that means is we're
saying 2 to the m divides x minus y. So if we write
that out algebraically, what that tells you is that
x minus y equals something - let's call it a - times
2 to the m. Because if this is going to be a factor
of that there has to be something else. So in our
previous example we had this was 96, we had 32 here,
so a would be 3. It's just that other integer part
of our division. So if 2 to the m divides that it,
means that. So if I now say, well what's y minus
x? Well that's just minus a times 2 to the m. So
the same power of 2 still divides the number the
other way around, we've just got a minus sign in front.
We don't care about that, we're in the integers so
we're allowed negative numbers. So-
- (So positivity)
(could go out the window there)
- Positivity does still
hold, because the function itself was the biggest
power of 2 that divides the number. So even though
there's a minus here, this- so this might be
-96, the biggest power of 2 is 32. So it's still the
biggest power of 2 multiplied by some integer, now
it's a negative one, but the power of 2 is still
positive so we're okay. So that gives us symmetry;
now triangle law, a little bit of work required.
Let's start by thinking about (x,y). Suppose this
is 1 over 2 to the m, and let's suppose the same
power also divides this one, 1 over 2 to them as well.
So we're sort of thinking here, what is
the largest power of 2 that divides both of these
two okay? And pick that one to be our distance for
these two. Because what we can then say is this
means x minus y is equal to uh some number - let's
call it a - times 2 to the m. This one means y
minus z is some number b times 2 to the m. These of
course could have powers of 2 in them, there could
be a bigger power of 2 that divides this one,
but we want a power of 2 that works on both of
them. And then if we try and work out this one- so
for here we have to consider x minus z. So what's
x minus z? We've got equations for things here so
we can say x minus z is- x is going to be y plus
a(2 to the m). And then we want to subtract off z,
we've got z - if I take it over there and do that - z is
y minus b(2 to the m). So x minus z we're going to
lose the ys and we've got minus minus becomes a
plus, so what we've got is a plus b times 2 to the
m. So what this is saying is if I have a power of 2
that divides x minus y, and a power- the same power
of 2 that also divides y and z, then it definitely
divides x minus z. And it can't get smaller;
if you sort of look at what's happening here,
because it divides these two, by this algebra it's
definitely a factor of this one. So it definitely
divides that one. But it can get bigger, the power
of 2 here could get bigger. Because a plus b, as I
mentioned here, these could have factors of 2 in.
So when you add them together this could contain
additional powers of 2, but that would just mean
this one had a larger power of 2 - what's our
definition of distance? It's 1 over that power.
So you could potentially have a bigger power of
2 dividing x minus z, but that means the distance
between x and z is smaller which is what we needed.
So that one's a little bit harder to get your
head around; and I recommend working through
this for yourselves actually because this is the
kind of crux of showing that this metric works.
But it will satisfy the triangle law and therefore,
as ridiculous as it may sound, the 2-adic metric
is a distance function.
- (Just because it matches
those things- I mean if I- if I said to you all)
(bananas are yellow and then I pulled out a yellow
Volkswagen, and I said look that's yellow so that)
(must be a banana as well - just because it happens
to meet the criteria it doesn't feel like to me)
(it has to still be a distance; you're telling
me it does?)
- It's- I I see your point but I think
if you were to define what it meant to be a
banana it would be: it is yellow, it is a fruit,
it has the curve- whatever it was there would be
several things. And so you would create almost
like an exhaustive list such that absolutely
everything- you had to tick every box on that
list and then you could be nothing but a banana.
- (You haven't convinced me though that this three)
(is exhaustive)
- Yeah well that's a fair point. So yeah,
I mean this is why they're called axioms, and this
is why this is the mathematical definition of adistance.
- (For this video I'll take your word for)
(it that that list is exhaustive.)
- Yes that this-anything satisfying these three things from the
mathematical perspective we call a distance. Now
our real world definition of distance fits these.
Okay, when we talk about the numbers and taking the
modulus it's obviously positive, symmetry and it
does satisfy the triangle law with the picture.
So the one we're used to in the real numbers
is a distance. Of course that doesn't in any way
prove that all distances have to look like this,
but the one we used to fits these rules, and it
just so happens that we can find other distances.
Some of them are sensible; like um great circles,
great arcs, on a sphere - they will also satisfy the
same kind of thing. But it just so happens that
here it it fits the axioms; we as mathematicians
have said if it fits the axioms it's a distance,
so we can now use it to measure distance for this
particular sequence.
- (All right, I'll let you do it.)
- We showed at the beginning that if this is going
to converge to some limit - which I'm telling
you is -1 - then what we need to show is that
the distance between the nth term, which we'll
work out in just a moment, of the sequence and
what we think the limit is which here is -1 we
need the distance of those two to tend to zero
as n goes to infinity. So we did the example with
n plus 2 over n plus 1 and we showed that that
does indeed tend to 1 because we got 1 over n plus
1 here. So as we make n bigger and bigger and
bigger, 1 over a bigger number we get zero. So
the nth term: well if this is the first term, it's
10 minus 1. This is the second term- so let's write that,
10 minus 1. This is 10 squared minus 1. 10 cubed minus
1 - so it's actually a nice and easy 10 to the n minus 1
is our nth term. So we need to show this and that
tells us that this sequence does indeed go to -1.
What's our definition of distance we're using? The
2-adic metric; because if we use the real numbers,
it obviously is infinity, that's no fun. We wanted
to get -1. So we need to find the largest power of
2 which divides that number minus that number.
So of course -1 plus 1 10 to the n. So what's
the largest power of 2 which divides 10 to the
n? Well 10 to the n is 2 to the n times 5 to the
n; because 10 is 2 times 5, 2 to the n is
a factor so our distance in the 2-adic metric
between the nth term of the sequence to the limit
-1 is 1 divided by 2 to the n. What happens
to this is n tends to infinity? 1 over a bigger
and bigger and bigger number, this tends to zero
as n tends to infinity. So what this means is n
tends to infinity is saying as the number in the
sequence - 10 to the n minus 1 - as this number gets
bigger and bigger and bigger, more and more 9s
in a row, the distance between this really big
number and -1 gets smaller and smaller. Because
in this measure of distance, the 2-adic space, in
this space the way that we measure the distance is
1 over the biggest power of 2 that divides it.
So this number is getting huge and it's getting
closer and closer to -1 in this space so we can
say the sequence of 9s converges to -1.
- (Does thishappen with a lot of other sequences? Like is this-)
(is this some unique property of numbers with
lots of 9s in it and the -1? Or could you pull-)
(could you manufacture other sequences where thishappens?)
- You can do this with any sequence you want.
So the 9s I just picked because it works quite
nicely with the algebra. The other thing you can
change is here we've done on a 2-adic metric, the
more general case is p-adic where p is a prime.
So you need a prime number for lots of reasons
but that again is, I'm going to say, a little bit
beyond what I'm trying to get across here in this
particular case. But as long as you pick any prime
number you can measure distance in the same way.
So you- for the 3-adic you would say it's the
biggest power of 3 that divides the difference
between these two numbers and then your distance
is 1 over 3 to that power, similar kindof idea.
- (So if you'd done 8 - 88, 888 and used)
(8s instead of 9s would this necessarily still
work? Does it depend on the numbers?)
- No that would
work. I think that- off the top of my head I want to
say that would be zero because 8's perfectly
divisible by 2. If you change the numbers
in your sequence the limit will change. So -1
here isn't special, that is just the limit for the
sequence with all the 9s. If you had a sequence with
all the 8s like you said you're going to get
a different limit - and it might not even converge.
It doesn't have to converge to something. Like
because I could write down an arbitrary sequence
that's not going to necessarily converge. So you do
have to be careful, it needs to be something which
almost has been like artificially constructed to
make sure it's going to converge, and then you need
to figure out what that limit is. And finding that
limit can be quite tricky. So I told you it was -1
but to actually work out why it's -1, a little
bit of work involved in that.
- (So possibly right)
(now we could put on the screen a few examples of
other sequences and what they converge to.)
- We could.
Our thanks to Jane Street for supporting this
video. Now you might be wondering, why is like
a high-flying, research driven, trading firm
supporting a Numberphile video? Basically it's
because they think the people watching - people like
you - are the sort of smart, curious, problem-solving
types. And maybe some of you could be the next
person to join their teams in the likes of New
York, London, or here in Hong Kong. Not sure how much
work I'd get done here actually, but anyway. There
are interesting jobs, internships, free programs
you can join; all sorts of stuff going on. Go to
janestreet.com and click here on 'Join Jane Street'
to find out more. This is a company that really
wants the best people, and it wants to look after
them to make sure their careers are interesting,
fun, successful; and you could be one of them
so go to janestreet.com, check out the website,
all your questions are answered there, and our
thanks to them for supporting this video.
Every time we have a pattern puzzle I'm going to write down thelist of numbers 1 through 16 in the
order that they appear in the tray so for example...